starting off this hour is rich in new
york hi rich how are you doing well
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up i am coordinating FPU for
the first time well thank you and dad
it's going great everyone is really into
it good and and I'm very happy to be
part of this there have been a few
questions that have come up two in
particular one I spoke to your screener
about and I'll ask that and if you have
time for one more I'll close that one
but the question is this Dave some of
the class members are concerned about
sacrificing hard to build savings
because they believe that the savings
will be taken away from them in the
FAFSA process and will be required to
give it to their students future college
so how would you respond to that god
help me god help us if we had a job so
we didn't get unemployment that's how I
would respond to that I mean so you know
lord help us who got wealth and we paid
for our kids college and so we didn't
qualify for government aid the FAFSA
process FAFSA stands for Free
Application for Federal Student Aid and
there's only one kind of federal student
aid and that's Pell grants and it's
based on people being poor it's federal
aid for poor people and so no I'm not
going to teach people to remain poor so
that they can't sit so that they can get
federal aid
that's what FAFSA spiria that's what
it's for
that's the only thing it does it's the
Free Application for Federal Student Aid
now what happens when you fill out the
FAFSA is you'll get hammered six ways
from Sunday with all kinds of student
loan possibilities in addition to that
it's a huge marketing forearm is really
what it is but the only thing you
qualify from federal government is
need-based and so it's for people that
are in poverty and I don't want to teach
people to stay in poverty in order to
get government aid do you I mean that's
not that's not lunch oh so yeah that's
so that's the overall answer now
is the thing go pile up a bunch of money
so that you don't need you know you know
I all three of my kids went through
college we did not fill out a single
FAFSA we wouldn't have qualified I make
too much money to get free aid the the
the students who are raising this
concern our students that have kids that
are real close to college and they don't
have the time they feel to get yet
wealthy so but if their income is high
they're not going to qualify anyway
right and so I mean if they're sitting
around a hundred thousand dollar
household income you're not gonna get a
Pell Grant and so you know what else and
all the other all the other ADA
scholarship yeah every other piece of
aid is one of three types of
scholarships athletic academic or
character based type scholarship so you
you know your church has one for a
thousand dollars or the the Kiwanis Club
has a 250 dollar scholarship and you
know you write an essay and you say why
you want to change the world and they go
Ward you the scholarship that kind of a
scholarship and there's there's you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars that
stuff out there to scratch around but
there's only one need but well I mean
there's probably some private need-based
scholarships by some foundations here or
there but the primary need-based would
be Pell grants with the federal
government but if you make a good income
and you own a nice home you don't
qualify for Pell even if you got no
money save for college and so you just
don't want to set yourself up for that's
the way we're going to do college now if
they've got students getting ready to
head into college then it's gonna be
tough you know you're sitting there
looking at a 16 year old but we're gonna
walk them down you know the Rachael Cruz
smart money smart kids guidelines on how
do you go to school
number one mathematical way you go to
school if your parents haven't saved any
money is you choose an affordable school
an in-state tuition school maybe
Community College for the first couple
years to get some of your course stuff
out of the way number two thing you do
is you work while you're in school and
no that's not child abuse all you people
out there that worked while you're in
school raise your hands yes I see those
millions of hands all across America all
of us did it's not child
use and I worked 40 to 60 hours a week
got out in four years because I needed
to get out I was tired of working and so
um you know you work while you're in
school you choose something that's good
you take the a CT the SAT numerous times
while you're in high school if you want
to spend some money on something parents
that are you got a 16 year old spend
some money on tutoring so they can take
that test and get a higher score help
them qualify for yet more scholarships
but I mean this is for people that are
poor unless unless we're dealing with
poor people in this class you know that
you know you may want to look at that
but the problem is is that we're saying
okay we're going to intentionally stay
poor for the next two years so that we
can get a Pell Grant I just I'm not
signing up for welfare I'm just as a way
of life and as a methodology so it's a
false premise to say if I save money I'm
gonna disqualify my kid for free federal
aid because in almost every case the
person saying that's not going to
qualify for the federal aid anyway they
have too much household income and so
it's very rare now you got a single mom
making 20k and she's got five kids yeah
they're gonna qualify but the chances of
her saving up a bunch of money and
disqualifying for the Pell Grant anyways
not there so anybody's asking the
question usually has the means to not
qualify if they have the means to screw
up their eligibility for Pell Grant they
have the means to not that they have too
much means to qualify meet the means
test is what I'm saying so it's a great
question rich I appreciate you bringing
it up but it's a mentality that we hear
people do I'm not gonna you know I I
want to I want to make sure I'm really
broke and we're gonna transfer all the
money out of mom and dad's name so they
qualify from Medicaid nursing home it's
the same discussion we're gonna hack
like we're poor when we're not so we
qualify for welfare nursing home is the
only government provided nursing home is
for welfare recipients it's a Medicaid
it's a means-test thing and so Papa and
granny in order to qualify for the you
know the the Medicaid nursing home have
to be legitimately broke it's for poor
people it's not for just people to go oh
I don't want to pay my nursing home
so I'm gonna move all my assets out of
my name into my kid's name they've got a
five year look-back and it's a criminal
it's a criminal act to hide money from
the federal government in order to
falsely qualify for Medicaid it's the
same kind of mentality though you got to
break through that as a part of and have
an abundance kind of mentality rather
than a sacrifice or a shortage mentality
so but it's a really good discussion
rich thank you for calling in with that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind